[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: All right.
How's everyone doing?
AUDIENCE: Great.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Great.
I got great on this side.
How about in the middle?
How y'all feeling?
AUDIENCE: Great.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Right.
And now over here,
how y'all feeling?
This side over here has got
more tea, caffeine, sugar.
They're feeling it.
I love it.
So as Shenaz was saying, my
name is Natalie Villalobos.
And I have the distinct
pleasure of serving all of you
as the head of Global Programs
for Women's Techmakers.
And today is one
of my favorite days
in the entire
year, which is when
I get to hang out with the
community, with my peers,
with colleagues, with
role models, with mentors,
and actually get to interview
one on stage with all of you.
So kind of how
it's going to go is
I'm going to have 30
minutes of some questions
that I've prepared.
And then we're
going to do some 15
minutes of audience Q&A. So with
that, I'd like to get started.
JULIA TIZARD: Be gentle
with me, Natalie.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I'll try.
JULIA TIZARD: Thanks.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
I don't know.
I'm going to try.
This is pretty serious.
All right.
So you're at Virgin Galactic.
JULIA TIZARD: Yes.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Right?
So we're going to start
from kind of some basics.
How did you get into
the space industry?
JULIA TIZARD: That's kind of
an interesting story, actually.
You can tell by my accent,
I'm not from the US.
I'm from England.
And I basically knew
from a very young age
that I wanted to get
into space somehow.
My dad was an
aeronautical engineer.
And I can remember
visiting his work
and traipsing
through wind tunnels
and seeing little
model airplanes
and just thinking it was
the coolest thing ever.
And then I'm not exactly
sure how the space connection
happened, but it
basically landed me
at university studying
for astrophysics.
And I had this just
like inside desire
to get into the
space sector somehow.
And for any of you that
know, England is not--
certainly, my generation was
not very active, at least
in the human space
flight portion of space.
It's quite difficult to
get into that in the UK.
And while I was in my very last
year of my PhD at Manchester
University, there was a prize
called the XPRIZE going on,
which I'm sure a lot of you
are familiar with, where
SpaceShipOne and Scale
Composites supported
by Paul Allen won that prize.
And I happened to be at
a conference in Vancouver
at the time.
And me and a bunch of friends
had been following the XPRIZE.
And we all decided--
well, we came from the
UK, we're in Vancouver.
LA, it's really
not that far away.
I'm a student at the time.
And I'm like, no one will really
notice if we jump on a plane,
fly down to LA, and go out and
see the final XPRIZE flight.
So that's what we did, like
literally one afternoon to get
there for the next morning.
And so myself and
a group of friends
jumped on that flight,
called up some friends we
had at Cal Tech, said get a
car, drive us out to the desert.
We got there about
5:00 in the morning,
slept for a couple
of hours, and then
got up to watch
the XPRIZE flight.
And that was when
Sir Richard Branson
announced that he was going to
bust into the market of space
tourism.
And I just got super
excited about that.
So I was like, not only
is this space tourism
and bringing space
to the public,
but it's also a British company
or a British-backed company
that's doing it.
So I went back home
after that trip
and spent the last six months
of my PhD writing my thesis
and going to every
single conference
that Virgin Galactic talked at
and talked to everyone I could
and convinced them to give
me a three month internship,
essentially, when I finished
my doctorate program.
And that was 11 years ago.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So it was interesting,
just even that journey when you
were saying, I got on a plane,
and then I was in the desert.
It's like, and then there
was a spaceship lifting off.
It reminded me of some times
I've gone to Burning Man.
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
JULIA TIZARD: I
have done that, too.
There are similarities.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
So I will say,
I used to say that I
was a rocket scientist.
Because I don't know
who's been to Burning Man,
but in 2009 I was one of
the builders of a four story
hand-rolled aluminum
rocket ship that we
told 60,000 people at Burning
Man was going to launch.
And so we had the
whole of Burning Man
waiting, when really it was
just a fancy pyrotechnic show.
So I'm kind of like
a rocket scientist.
JULIA TIZARD: I'm
right there with you.
I think that's super cool.
I am fortunate that I get to
do that as my day to day job.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, I'm pretty jealous.
So as a part of your day
job, can you tell us,
this dream that I
think many of us
have of going into
space and space tourism,
how are you making that into
a reality with your role
at Virgin Galactic?
JULIA TIZARD: And so I run
operations at Virgin Galactic,
which is a very
broad term, means
a lot of things, a lot
of different things a lot
of different people.
But basically, what
that means for my job
is that it runs the gamut of
looking after and supporting
the pilot teams, the
maintenance teams that
service the vehicles, the
flight test portion, all
the way through to the
training and medical pieces
that the customers, once
the vehicle is ready,
the training and medical
programs that they
will go through to get them
onto the flight as well.
So it's pretty much
almost the whole product.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
The whole show.
JULIA TIZARD: I, obviously,
don't do all of that myself.
I have a huge, amazing
team that does a lot
of the intricate work for that.
But in the 11 years that
I've been in the company,
I've kind of worked in
almost every sector,
and then hired the
team that is now
in place that puts the
smarts and the talent to it.
And we are right now
flight testing a vehicle.
It's a two-stage system, White
Knight Two and a SpaceShip.
The White Knight Two
is the mothership.
The SpaceShip attaches
to the mothership,
climbs up to 50,000 feet,
releases the SpaceShip,
SpaceShip launches up
into suborbital space
and comes back down and
lands just as a glider.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: You
make it sound really simple.
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
It's not simple.
But, you know, it's
also like if you
put the right amount of people
and the right talent of people
with the right passion on
a job, you can pretty much
achieve anything.
It just takes some
time sometimes.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: You also
have the first female space
flight test pilot on your team.
JULIA TIZARD: Yes, we do.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And what
is her role like right now?
JULIA TIZARD: So she's
fully-fledged one
of the test pilots on our team.
So she plays both a role
in the mission control
when she's not actively
flying the vehicles.
We like to have a pilot
on the ground talking
to pilots in the vehicles.
So all of the pilots perform
that function if they're not
in either the right or left--
so the copilot or pilot seat--
of either the White
Knight Two, which
is the mothership,
or the SpaceShip Two,
which is the space ship.
They have to do a lot of
flight training for that.
So we also have additional
vehicles an extra [INAUDIBLE],,
which they do a lot of G
training and just more complex
aircraft air practice in.
And then they're
in the simulator
all the time running
simulations both independently
with their fellow
pilots to make sure they
have a really good
relationship in the cockpit,
and they really go
through those procedures.
And it has to be very
smartly timed and very cued
off each other.
And then they also
do those simulations
with the wider team
in mission control
as well to make
sure that we can run
through lots of
different situations
that we might find in flight.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
a big part, I would say,
of that excitement
to go into space
is the spirit of adventure.
And can you tell me a
little bit about how
the spirit of adventure
and the challenge, how
that plays into your work and,
I guess, your day-to-day role?
JULIA TIZARD: So for me what
I'm all about fundamentally,
regardless of space or whatever
I'm doing, is adventure.
Adventure is the one word that
really kind of sums me up.
I think it is critically
important to everybody
to find their own
piece of adventure,
because I really feel like
it helps self-development,
really pushing your boundaries
to get to know yourself.
And I also believe it is
critically important for teams
as well to help
kind of put people
together with a central
objective to really go
challenge themselves.
And when you're
working on a program
like trying to take
people to space,
there is, obviously, a lot
of challenges both technical,
personal, inter-relational.
Pretty much they
run the full gamut.
And so you really
have to have people
that are willing to tackle
those, that have the passion
to tackle them, and the
courage and the commitment
to see them through as well.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And you even said
when we were having a
chance to chat this week
that you really have to break.
To be a better
human, you have to go
beyond your personal boundaries.
You have to get uncomfortable.
Can you speak to that?
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
So I think probably
the best way that I
would put it is that I do
a lot of mountain climbing.
And, actually, I am taking
a temporary breather
from mountain climbing to
having children right now.
I climb smaller
mountains these days.
But I do a lot of
mountain climbing.
And for me, that is a lot
about pushing yourself, again,
to get to know who you are.
But a bigger portion
of that is really
kind of getting a fresh
perspective on things.
I really, truly believe
that humans are just
incredibly capable beings
and that most people have
no idea actually what they're
capable of until they really
push themselves and set
themselves higher goals
and set themselves
higher challenges.
And you have to be willing
to fail at those things
in order to push
yourself that far.
And we also have this other
tendency as human beings
to get distracted by
things that seem very, very
big in the moment, but
actually in the scope of things
really aren't big.
We've all had those break ups
with a spouse or a boyfriend
or girlfriend.
We've had Monday mornings
really not working for us,
being in traffic
jams, and feeling
like the world is breaking down.
And those things
really get in our way.
And when you can put some
adventure and some challenge
in your life, you get a totally
radical perspective change
on the world.
And that is one of
the things that I'm
excited to work towards
getting, essentially,
a civilization to space.
Because I think the
perspective shift that's
going to come with that that
is real and experienced rather
than just
knowledge-based I think
is going to fundamentally
change us as human beings.
It will really put us
in to the space age.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
I was kind of thinking of the
movie "Wall-E" for a second,
where you get everyone
on a big spaceship.
But I think it's going to
take maybe 10 at a time or 100
at a time.
I don't know if we can take
a whole civilization yet.
Yeah.
When you were
speaking to adventure,
it's a big rallying
cry in my life.
It's a big kind of
theme and motto.
So one of the things that
I really like to do is,
if I can't add it in every day--
because we've got the mundane,
we've got our eight hours of
meetings and things like that--
is my partner and I,
Timothy, we have something
called adventure Sunday.
And adventure Sunday is
where we spend a whole day
just doing something
we've never done before.
So you can very easily
practice adventure.
We've done flying
trapeze lessons.
He's also taken me to
do a walk with a hawk
and learned falconry.
So there's definite things where
I'm challenging myself just
to put my technology away
and just go adventure
in mind, body, and spirit.
And I think that
that also helps me
bring just a more clear present
sense of myself into my work,
say, on that Monday.
JULIA TIZARD: And
it's a lot of fun.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yes.
Cool.
So a couple of space questions.
So how do you see
the space industry
influencing the tech
industry and vice versa?
JULIA TIZARD:
Interesting question.
So I mean, I think in a
whole multitude of ways,
you only have to go
back to the Apollo days
to realize they ran an entire
Luna mission on less computing
power than we have in
our handheld phones.
In fact, I think it's
like 100 or 1,000 times
less computing power
than is in our phones.
And space in general has shown
a very long-lasting trend
of just spin-off
technologies coming out
of the challenge
of the innovation
that it takes to get
yourself into those types
of environments.
Velcro is one example.
It's not tech, but we wouldn't
have that in the world
if it hadn't been for
the space program.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Velcro's life-changing.
JULIA TIZARD: So, yeah.
And so I think there's
a natural dynamic there.
Anytime you're pushing the
boundaries to do something,
you need the tools to do it.
And also, you take a tool
and you use it in one way.
And you find out
that, actually, it's
very useful in a
myriad of other ways.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And so we
have 300 women in this room.
We will have 14,000
women connecting with us
over the next couple of months.
How can women in this room and
in other parts of the world,
online, everywhere-- what
is the thing that we should
do either as women or just
as technologists really--
it doesn't matter your gender.
It could be non-gender
binary, gender non-conforming.
What can we do to participate
in space exploration?
JULIA TIZARD: So I think
a couple of things.
And Communication is always
a huge one for any company.
And it's particularly
important in the space arena
as well, just because programs
tend to be highly dynamic
and move very fast.
So we live in a
world right now where
communication tools are
extremely elevated from where
they used to be.
And those are real
enablers to the function
of working in a company.
The same with collaborative
spaces as well.
It's just my opinion, but
in the space industry,
it's come from a kind
of old space arena
where each person had an
individual job that they did.
And each of those
individual jobs
added up to create the whole.
And I think we're moving
in this shift in new space
to a much more collaborative
working environment.
And we're seeing the strengths
in working in small teams
and making sure that we're
much better integrated
and that we're doing that
right at the beginning
of the program, rather
than it being a stage later
on in the program.
So those kind of
tools as well are just
incredibly important to us.
And then I think the obvious
one pretty much to everyone
is just promotion, both to bring
business funds and investment
in, but also to
provide inspiration
and education for the
next generation as well.
If we don't have the talented
workforce to do these things
and to rise to these challenges,
then we can't do any of them.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
So I used to do a lot
of Citizen Science work.
So I was recently
reading an article
about how DIY makers and
scientists are trying
to put together the science and
learn the science themselves
to be able to put themselves
into space without, say, SpaceX
or Virgin Galactic.
And governments are
getting involved,
and companies are
getting involved.
So this is a pretty highly
competitive landscape, right?
So can you tell me and
share some insights
on what it has taken to drive
the space program at Virgin
Galactic given this
very technically
competitive landscape?
JULIA TIZARD: So I guess I'll
answer that question maybe
from a non-technical
perspective to start off with.
A big part of the role I
play in Virgin Galactic
as a company is in
the kind of business
strategic end of things as well
as kind of in the tech end.
And from that perspective,
really the reason
Virgin Galactic exists is
because of the commitments
of the Virgin Group and
of Sir Richard Branson
and the investment partners to
continually fund the program.
And they realize the
innate value in it.
And without those
backers, you just
wouldn't get off of the ground.
And there was some great
talks earlier today
just on people having
founded companies
and really realizing how
much of a pot of gold
that is to have someone who
believes in a product enough
and can see the end value
in the product enough
to really keep
fundamentally backing it.
I think Virgin has an edge
there in terms of our input
to the space industry, just
because the Virgin Group
portfolio is a very, very
diverse investment portfolio.
So it tends to be quite stable.
And when you're doing anything
in the space environment,
it does cost high dollars.
So you either have to have
a single person bankrolling
that who has a lot of them
or a more stable investment
platform that can continually
kind of feed you those funds
to create it.
So I think that's one side.
On the tech side, we are
fortunate that Richard Branson
saw an opportunity
in a specific system
that Burt Rutan had
designed with what
we call a feathering
system, which
is a new technology, a new
re-entry technology, to come
back from space.
It works in the
suborbital arena,
just because the
energies that you
have to lose coming
through the atmosphere
are in around where this
feathering system works.
But that is fundamentally a
new technology on our vehicles
that is innovation,
that is giving us
a different model
of spaceflight.
And it takes away the
high G's of re-entry.
It takes away a lot
of the heat that you
have on that re-entry back
into the atmosphere as well.
And so that's definitely
an area that, I guess,
we have a different
product on the market.
I will say that Virgin is
very friendly to competition
and actually encourages it
in a lot of our industries.
And I think that is
equally important in space.
Because you never know
which technology out
there is going to be successful.
You need a myriad of
those technologies
in order to have one or two
that really work and thrive.
And other people come up with
spaceship designs that work,
then we would
absolutely operate them.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Awesome.
JULIA TIZARD: If anybody wants
to start a space company out
there, feel free.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
You can come pitch
her afterwards.
Yeah.
I think we could
go tour it later.
But there's a model
of a Virgin Galactic--
it's much smaller-- in one
of the Google lobbies--
JULIA TIZARD: Nice.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
--which is something
that's always inspired
me when I first
started working at Google.
I was like, oh,
man, space ships.
So thank you so much
for sharing that.
And I want to pivot
just a little bit, too.
So going back into a
little bit of your story,
you briefly touched on
so you climb mountains.
You've also run a marathon,
or many marathons,
but one specifically
at the North Pole--
JULIA TIZARD: Yes.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
--which I assume
is pretty challenging
in and of itself.
And in the work
that you're doing,
space tourism and supporting all
the people that you're doing,
it sounds pretty challenging.
And I want to know
are there moments
where you want to give up?
And in those moments
where you want to give up,
what kept you going?
JULIA TIZARD: So
there's a couple of--
we'll get to the answer.
But I'm going to precede this
with a little bit of context.
The reason or one of the reasons
I like running long distance
or marathons is-- and I think
there's a quote out there that
goes along the lines of--
you can learn anything you want
to learn about yourself running
26.2 miles.
And that is very, very true.
We are human beings with these
little voices in our head.
And really, physically, if
you can run a half marathon,
your body is able
to run a marathon.
The difference that that second
part of the marathon takes
is you being trained to
be kind enough to yourself
to keep encouraging
yourself to finish.
And that's really probably
the biggest strength
that I take out of running
marathons and marathon
training.
And it absolutely applies
to any challenging task
that you kind of put
in front of yourself.
And then there's a
second component.
Look at the North Pole race.
So I came up with
this crazy idea.
I was reading all these
books about exploration.
And I happened to be reading
about the North and South Pole
and Roald Amundsen, and Scott
and Shackleton, and Peary.
And I was really inspired
to go to the pole.
And so I must've been
googling online somewhere.
And I came across this
marathon at the North Pole.
And I was like, hey, I'd
like to run long distance.
That would be amazing.
I looked it up.
And it's like, oh, it's
17,500 pound entrance fee.
How am I going to do that?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Do
they have scholarships?
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
JULIA TIZARD: And then it
actually was fortunate,
because Virgin was taking
over the London Marathon
the same year.
It had been the Flora
Marathon for a very long time.
But Virgin was taking
it over that same year.
And the date of the
North Pole Marathon
was like two weeks before
the London Marathon.
And I was like, wow, you know,
I work for Virgin in the cutting
edge of Virgin space industry.
So surely, if I run a
marathon in the North Pole
two weeks before the London
Virgin Marathon launches,
that's going to be a really cool
promotional thing for Virgin.
And so I literally flew off
like one or two emails to people
to kind of say,
hey, would this be
at all something
that was interesting,
not thinking that the answer
I was going to get was yes.
And it turned out it was.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Then you had to commit.
JULIA TIZARD: Oh.
Great, yeah.
So [INAUDIBLE] I was
like, oh, my goodness.
I guess I am running a
marathon at the North Pole.
The most interesting
part about that is I
had actually never run a
marathon at that point in time.
So the North Pole Marathon
was my first ever marathon.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
You didn't mention
that at all like in your
bio or when we were talking.
That's insane.
JULIA TIZARD: It is insane.
But the beauty about
that was that I
trained so hard for that
race, because I was really
scared of it.
And the amazing thing was
that once I got there,
there was I think probably
25 other people who
were running this marathon
who were all people who
just ran marathons.
That was their thing.
That was what was normal
to them in their life,
because they'd run 50 before.
And they'd already run
across the Greenland ice
sheet or the Sahara Desert.
So being there with
that group of people,
I actually wasn't running
this crazy scary marathon
at the North Pole.
I was just running a
marathon doing the things
that those people did every day.
And I was joining them.
It was this massive
leveler of a playing field.
And all of a sudden, what I was
doing that day became ordinary.
And I think that's what
enabled me to achieve it.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And you
didn't feel intimidated by it.
It was like, these
are my people.
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
This is my community.
JULIA TIZARD: And that is
exactly the power of community.
Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Yeah, absolutely.
So I want to throw in kind of
one of the random questions
that I--
I mean, I love writing
all these questions.
But this one in
particular, I think,
was just really striking for me.
So I know there's a
dramatic suspenseful pause
in the audience.
If you are an intergalactic
real estate agent
and you needed to
sell someone on why
they should buy a house on
Mars, what would your pitch be?
JULIA TIZARD: Real estate agent.
OK.
Intergalactic real estate agent.
Well, I mean, I would
go at the drop of a hat,
mostly for the adventure of it.
That's not everybody's
cup of tea.
I would probably talk to
them about how amazing
the rocket ride was
going to be to get there,
how incredible the whole
thought process was
going to be of how do
you build a house on Mars
and how that might be different
from how it would be on Earth.
One of the things that I've
always loved about space
and that I've always had the
best conversations about space
on is that it is almost this
arena for a thought experiment.
You don't have to
take anything with you
when you put your mind
in the perspective
of, especially, more
far out space travel.
You don't have to bring a
political system with you.
You don't have to bring
your 2.5 children,
suburban home with you.
You get to create
something entirely new.
And it kind of releases you
from a lot of the constraints
that you would naturally
have these default settings
when you're looking
at things on Earth.
So I would probably
pitch it as something
that you could get very
actively involved in
and create your own home.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Create your own planet.
JULIA TIZARD: Create
your own planet.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Create your
own house, planet, government.
JULIA TIZARD: And sell
it to all your friends.
Because, obviously, you want
to have all your friends there.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It's
kind of like a land grab,
and then you can sell
off pieces of it.
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
JULIA TIZARD: You know what's
interesting about that, too?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Sell me on it.
On Sell me on it.
JULIA TIZARD: Who knows
if we'll even have money?
You don't even have
to take money to Mars.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: It's just
like a barter and trade system,
or you just wink.
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
A new currency?
JULIA TIZARD: You know,
tap the red shoes,
the heels of the red
shoes together, right?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yeah.
That would be mandatory in
my intergalactic government.
Everyone wears
sparkly red shoes.
Yeah.
So like I said, we have
so many incredible women
here in New York, in
Seattle, in Lagos, Sydney.
And we're all passionate.
We're all people who
are powerful and can
change the game.
So what startup should
someone in this room
create to get ahead
of and participate
in the space tourism industry?
JULIA TIZARD: That's
a good question.
There are so many things,
so many things that we need.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And then we don't have
to tell anyone else in here.
Like, someone can
just take this idea,
and then just run with it.
JULIA TIZARD: And run with it.
OK.
Well, attire, we are
right in the thick right
now of figuring out what
our everyday astronauts are
going to wear in space.
And I mean, it totally can have
a massive fashion bent to it.
But there is actually a
technical piece to that
as well.
You know, the skin
of our space ship
is likely to be below freezing.
It is carried at 50,000
feet for a period of time
before it's released,
and then you're
going into space
vacuum environment.
So it gets very cold.
So people will need
to wear gloves.
So something as simple
as, go invent some gloves
that you can really get
the most enjoyment out
of weightlessness.
So they need to be very free.
But they also need to be great
materials and all that stuff
for working in weightlessness.
Gosh.
I mean, we have had
bizarre requests
for taking things to space all
the way from ashes to pets to--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Like, live pets?
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
To a--
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I'm
just thinking [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIA TIZARD: --whole
bunch of different gamuts.
And we have not solved any
of those problems of how
we could do any of those items.
So I don't know if you could
look at things like that.
I'm trying to think of something
real fundamental to what
we need right now.
I think the training is the
other big aspect as well.
You know, we're very focused
on the hardware right now.
But training customers to be
able to go and utilize space
or to be able to go and utilize
the time they have in space
is very important.
And there's a very specific
art to that as well.
And it's not just about
what you have to know
and what you have to do.
And, actually,
the environment is
pretty passive in our
particular vehicle.
But it's how do you get
people comfortable with being
inside a cabin for a
long period of time
with a couple of other people?
How do you get people
comfortable with the noises
they're going to hear
from the rocket motor
when they're released?
How do you address all of
those kind of potential anxiety
issues that we may see
with some of our customers?
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And what
about health monitoring, right?
When I think of NASA and when
I've visited Houston, I mean,
you've got to go through some
pretty rigorous health tests.
So what is that kind of like
for getting people into space?
JULIA TIZARD: That is actually
a really great area for us
to look at and for any of
you guys to look at, too.
Health monitoring
would be super helpful.
We actually did a lot of
work on the medical portion
of our spaceflight endeavor.
We are taking the everyday
person into space.
And one of the things we
realized very early on
is that we had this technical
challenge with the vehicles.
But then we also had this
potentially medical challenge
with our customers in that it's
not like NASA astronauts where
we're--
excuse me-- pre-selecting
them to be healthy
fit individuals to go to space.
We are taking the people
that can, right now, afford
the tickets.
And that tends to be
an older generation.
Not all the time,
but in general,
it tends to be an
older generation.
And it also tends to be people
who have lived life fully.
So they have a lot of the
regular medical issues
that you would expect.
And it is a big
unknown, actually.
So what happens
with those people
when you put them
under high G-forces,
and then through
weightlessness, and then
through all that
kind of anxiety?
So we did a lot
of work hiring out
a centrifuge, which is one
of those big things that
spins around to
simulate high G-forces.
And we actually had
all of our customers
go through that
centrifuge and ride
the profile of the vehicle,
so that we could collect
information from them
to feel good about where
we could accept or not accept
those medical conditions.
And on the whole,
the answer we got
was that pretty much nothing
was in the way of people going.
And people couldn't
have current disease.
But if they had past disease
and it was controlled,
it was actually
working out very well.
But it is something that we
would want to monitor and get
a lot more
information on just so
that we can expand
the ability for people
to ride on our space ships.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I love it.
I love increased
access for more people.
So I can sit here and
talk to her all day.
But I think what's more
important is to hear
more voices in the room.
So we actually have some mic
runners in the room holding up
some mics.
And we would love to
take some live questions.
So mic runners, will
you do your thing?
Sure, we'll start over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for this talk.
It was really interesting.
There's a lot of space
themed talks today.
One of my friends was
really interested in NASA.
And I said, oh, why
should we invest in NASA?
And she made the point that
every dollar invested in NASA
actually was profitable
for the US Government.
And I was wondering how that
compared in the private sector.
JULIA TIZARD: So I think
it probably doesn't
compare in the private sector.
I mean, the private sector is
literally all private money.
It goes to the jobs of the
people working on the program
and to the technology
that's being created.
I definitely believe there
is a huge role for NASA
and government
programs in space.
And there is also a huge
role for the private sector.
And the way I like
to see that split
is that the private sector
has a lot more ability
to be able to run fast, to be
able to do R&D a lot quicker,
and also to be able to
scale a lot quicker as well
than perhaps NASA or a
government agency can do.
So where we have found strength
is that the private sector
takes on these kind of
current projects of scaling
current technology and doing
some element of development
as well, but basically getting
the cost of access to space
down.
And then the government
agencies really
can focus on the science
and the real far future R&D
where we are changing
different propulsion systems,
finding our warp
drive that we really
need today to be able to
get further out into space,
and to be focused on those kind
of bigger future projects that
will then support the commercial
industry in expanding them
and making them more readily
available and more cost
effective.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
focus of the government
to have research go
back into the public?
Whereas, private tends to
be more focused on scaling?
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
And making a profit, too.
I mean, that's what
we're all here for is
that any private company that
is into space is doing it,
because they believe there's
a business case behind it
as well.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Great.
All right.
One in the middle.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You spoke earlier about
reaching and trying for things
that you're not
sure that you can do
and not being afraid to fail.
And that is something
that a couple other people
today have spoken about.
What advice do you have
for when you do feel?
How do you pick yourself back
up and regain your confidence
after falling flat on your face?
JULIA TIZARD: So
this one I always
have a little bit of
a hard time answering.
Because if you want my honest
just direct answer on that
is that you just do it.
And I don't mean that to
belittle the situation at all.
But a lot of the time people
struggle picking themselves
up and continuing
on something is
because we've created something
out of the act of failing.
And so what I always
encourage people to do
is we should be living lives
where failing and being
successful have equal value.
You learn something out of
any of those situations.
And being able to
pick yourself up
and turn those things
around, because you failed.
Oh, I just failed.
You know, that's great.
I learned this.
Let's move on.
It's a mindset that you
have to train yourself into.
And it's hard.
I've been there and lost
confidence a number of times
almost to the point where I
just kind of got sick of it
and just decided, you know what?
I have to shut that
part of my brain
off that tells me
to lose confidence.
And I literally just
have to take action
to either go for what
you were going for again
or change direction and
choose what the next thing is
if you think you're not able.
It's either a cut
off, or it's something
you just need to try again.
So whichever one of
those two things it is,
I would really just focus on
the action of recommitting
and doing it again.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
And I'll add to that.
So I think one of the
things that my team knows
is that vulnerability
is a strength.
So for me if I
have a hard day, I
can lose confidence
10 times in one day.
I can go to 10
different meetings,
get 10 different answers.
I can be with so many
different kinds of people.
Some will say yes,
some will say no.
I'll try to negotiate.
So some days I just
have a hard cry.
I just go, and I get
in my comfy sweatpants.
And I get a cup of tea,
I cuddle with my cat.
And I just let it out.
Because I think one
of the hardest things
is when we feel like
we have to hold it.
Right?
And it's OK to
just spill it out.
It's OK to in your
lowest moments
just like have a moment where
you're taking care of yourself.
My team also knows I like
to take lots of baths.
A member of my team got
me lots of bath bombs.
Because that's one of my things.
That's my taking care of myself.
It's interesting when
you said the word fail,
your hand went here.
But I think a lot of times
failure is this lesson.
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Right?
We get feedback a lot of Google.
It's a practice of giving
and receiving feedback.
And one of the things, too,
is you're getting feedback.
And you're like, that's not me.
That sucks.
That's not what I
want to listen to.
But I think one of
the strongest things
that you can do in that moment
is just to say, thank you.
It's this humbling moment where
you're like I see that lesson.
And I'm going to
acknowledge that lesson.
And I'm going to choose what
I want out of that lesson.
And it's a very
empowering moment
around failure or learning.
And then from that, you
can go have a hard cry.
You can drink some wine.
Drink some tea, cuddle with the
cat or your animal of choice.
And then you start
fresh the next day.
And you don't have
to take what happened
on Monday into Tuesday.
You can just leave it on Monday.
And you can start again.
And so failure doesn't
have to be low.
It doesn't have to
be something that you
think no one else experiences.
We all experience it.
And I think that's a powerful
thing about community
is when we share that
vulnerability with each other.
So is there another mic
runner, another question?
All right, over here.
[INAUDIBLE] going to
have to work for it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm just curious,
especially when
you said that Virgin is very
friendly with its competitors,
I was just thinking about that.
How different are you
from your competitors?
And suppose you get
scooped and somebody else
becomes the dominant technology?
How would Virgin adapt to that?
JULIA TIZARD: So
my honest belief
on that is that if a competitor
is funding another technology,
and they come up with the
goods, and they make it,
and they have a space
flight system that
is going to take people to
space with an experience
that Virgin thinks
is worthwhile,
they would absolutely
invest in it, especially
if the route that we were
going was not working.
I mean, hopefully, the
route that we're going
does work and becomes
very profitable,
and we have more money then
to go purchase the other types
of experience items.
And part of the reason
I say that, too,
is that Virgin Galactic is an
unusual company for Virgin.
Virgin typically doesn't get
into manufacturing anything,
let alone space ships.
But they're really operators
and the customer end,
like with their
transport airlines,
with their other
products that they sell.
And really they're very customer
focused and experience-driven.
And the reason we are building
and doing R&D on spaceships
right now is because
no one else is.
And so if there were
other viable companies
out there working
on other vehicles,
and there are, and
they're successful,
then I absolutely don't doubt
that Virgin will go look
at them as a comparison
to our program
to see if there's
compatibility, to see if there's
strength one over the other.
And I also think
that just in general
the more people that are
successful doing things,
especially when you're starting
with a nascent industry
like human spaceflight and
public human spaceflight,
the more people
that are doing it
and the more people that are
out there successful, the more
investment is going to come into
that business to iterate on it
and to improve it and to
get it to a better place.
And that is also
something that Virgin
appreciates and understands.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: And if you
want help building a spaceship,
I'll help you.
I like that.
I mean, maybe it can't be made
out of hand-rolled aluminum
from Burning Man.
But I think that when you get
a bunch of people building
something with so
much passion, it
becomes something really great.
So if you wanted to create
a space startup, I got you.
All right.
Is there any other
questions in the room?
We've got one all the
way over here, too.
All right.
In the front.
AUDIENCE: So I just
want to know how safe it
is to go to a space comparing
to other transportation systems?
Because if I want
to go to a space,
that would be my main concern.
Thanks.
JULIA TIZARD: So I can
answer that a couple of ways.
And we are obviously
very focused on safety.
We have no business case if we
can't bring people back safely
from space.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
That's a good point.
JULIA TIZARD: That is
very, very important.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: You
can't leave them out there.
JULIA TIZARD: Yeah.
We also have no business
if we take no risk.
And taking people to
space is a risky business.
You There are your
typical known knowns,
your known unknowns, and
your unknown unknowns, right?
And in the space
arena, there is risk
that you're taking
on any endeavor
that you're doing there.
So my advice for you
is that you should
fly after several
people have flown.
Because there'll be more
information available then.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: That
means that the first few space
flights are still
going to be safe.
JULIA TIZARD: But that's
really important, right?
This is where I'm
talking about--
and this is actually
my day-to-day job--
balancing that risk.
We have to fly the
vehicles to test
them to understand whether
they meet the design that we've
designed them for.
So there is risk in
doing that, because we've
designed a vehicle
that we think is safe.
But until you really
fully test it,
you can't verify that
it's met the design
that you've designed it to.
So there's risk.
There's a larger risk in
us doing the test flight
phase of it.
Every piece of that test
flight that we go through
and every envelope that we
expand as we're doing that test
flight gives us
more data to make
us feel more confident in
that system and to tweak it,
to improve it, to push it to
a place where it's even safer.
So literally the first
people, the first customers,
that are going to
go in that vehicle,
they will be taking a
greater level of risk
than the people that
come five years later.
Because it will have only
flown a limited number of time.
And that's part of
why we can consider
those customers our
pioneers, almost part
founders in the company.
Because they are not
only putting their money
where their mouth is, but
they're also joining us
on this endeavor
of trying to make
spaceflight a reality for
everyone in this room.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: So
speaking of new endeavors,
I wanted to take one last
question from the room.
Can Finn join us?
He's hiding.
Thanks, Tony.
So this is something Julie
and I were talking about,
bringing Finn up on stage.
Finn.
JULIA TIZARD: So this is my
latest adventure, motherhood.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Hi.
Yeah.
We've all been flirting
with him all day.
Hi.
JULIA TIZARD: So this was
important to me to do.
I'm a very new mother.
I actually have a
two-year-old as well,
but I'm still a new mother.
I was never one of
those people that
was even really sure I was
going to have children.
And they are the most
humbling things in the world.
But also, they teach you a
lot and inspire you greatly.
And I just wanted to kind
of put that out there.
A lot of people have
talked about a lot
of the great women that have
been up here today have kids.
And being a new mom, I am in
awe of every single one of them.
Because it is hard to balance
family life and a work life.
But it is also totally doable.
And Finn here is
evidence of that.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: Yay.
JULIA TIZARD: Yay.
[APPLAUSE]
NATALIE VILLALOBOS: I
kind of want to just keep
doing this to make him smile.
Yeah.
Thanks for joining us, Finn.
So with that, we still have
another great talk coming up.
Yeah.
It could be you
if you wanted to.
But I want to thank you all
for sharing your questions.
And thank you to Julia and
to Finn for joining us,
for flying out from LA to join
us from the Virgin Galactic
team.
JULIA TIZARD: I'm
privileged to be here today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]